this youtuber made 12 million dollars by
secretly pumping and dumping crypto and
no one caught him until now in public he
says irresponsible sellers should be hit
by a bus yet behind the scenes he's been
relentlessly selling the cryptocurrency
safe moon to his gullible followers in
recent months he's used his new wealth
to buy a rolls royce he's now flying
private jets and he's bragging about
literally eating meals made of gold now
if you're wondering what is paying for
these luxuries and look online for
answers currently all you'll see is a
rag to riches story about how this
youtuber went from being homeless to
making millions of dollars because of
sick pranks he uploaded to youtube
however financial records show a
different story and no one would have
found out about this had it not been for
one individual who tipped me off my name
is uh lewis and i have some interesting
information about one of the one of the
premier leagues behind uh safe moon so
to back up a second i've been talking to
a lot of people about my safe moon
investigation and at one point i held an
open room where anyone could come in and
talk about their experiences be it
positive or negative what comes to mind
when you say safe moon i think um scam
and i think
pump and dump to me i see it as a long
term hold i've seen a lot of people get
into it kind of yellow all their money
in just [ __ ]
and everything was going normally until
the unexpected happened this guy joined
he's a youtuber named seizean and he's
about to make a very serious accusation
one of the promoters of safe moon was
dumping safe moon while obviously saying
oh i'm holding to the moon guys and
while he was tweeting those things was
was unloading uh literally millions of
dollars worth of moon wait a second that
could be criminal what is this
influencer's name ben phillips uk is his
twitter account wait a second
ben phillips is a famous uk youtuber he
runs a prank channel he's got hundreds
of thousands of followers on twitter and
most importantly he was involved with
safe moon since march 25th 2021 as part
of their marketing team is ben phillips
um if you haven't seen me i'm actually a
youtuber i think it's it's absolutely
incredible you know what's going on with
the community themselves being just like
picked up my twitter and being like yeah
let's go so this is the guy being
accused of a pump and dump scheme but
how do we know if this is true well if
you look today at bin phillips twitter
account for answers you won't find much
most of his statements have been deleted
and that's for good reason because in
one of them ben phillips does what you
should never do if you pump and dump
crypto he leaked his wallet quote if
anyone wants to buy me starbucks today
this is my bmb address now many of you
have watched the show long enough to
know what a huge admission this is and
how this can be used to find out
everything ben was doing with safe moon
and the first thing we find is that he
was definitely being paid for his role
in promoting safe moon the day he joins
the team the 25th of march he starts
getting paid in safe moon by the
deployer wallet he ends up getting paid
several more times a total of 5 trillion
safe moon tokens for his services but
what was interesting was not when he got
safe moon but when he decided to sell it
we can check this using archived tweets
from bin phillips twitter account and we
cross-reference that with the blockchain
to see his financial activity at the
same time and here's what we found a
pattern of pumping and dumping safe moon
with on the one hand positive tweets
about safe moon while at the same time
ben phillips would be dumping the coins
for a large profit onto the same people
who rushed in to buy based on his tweets
for example ben phillips tweeted holy
[ __ ] doge new all-time high and now safe
moon on its way to hitting new all-time
high tonight who's glad they holding not
financial advice that very same day been
sold 44 000
and these dumps escalate as we go
further into april on the 20th he
tweeted diamond hands always win and
then tweeted again fire sale that same
day he sold three times for over a
million dollars
the next day while tweeting about an
all-time high he said i feel bad for
everyone who sold again his next tweet
i feel bad for everyone who sold and
then this well i'm holding that same day
he sold three times again for over half
a million dollars these are clear pump
and dumps if he really thought there was
a fire sale on safe moon why sell a
million dollars of it and why would you
sell half a million dollars of safe moon
right after you say well i'm holding the
reason is obvious he wanted the price to
be as high as possible when he sold and
once ben phillips started making
millions of dollars in such a short
period of time what does he do with that
money he starts spending it on stupid
luxury items and bragging about it on
instagram of course for example on may
21st a month after making millions from
pump and dumps ben phillips suddenly
buys his dream car a quote top of the
fleet rolls royce a month later ben is
chartering private jets to scotland for
a birthday bite with his girlfriend of
three years he also can be seen bragging
on instagram about eating steak wrapped
in 24 karat gold now it should be noted
i'm not against people making money or
promoting a product that they believe in
but this isn't that ben phillips is
profiting millions of dollars from
publicly praising safe moon saying he's
holding safe mode saying it's a good buy
while secretly selling it he talked a
lot during his pump and dump days about
responsible versus irresponsible whales
he compares himself to a responsible one
someone who owns a lot of the token and
isn't going to sell it suddenly he can
trash this with irresponsible whales who
sell suddenly he says these people
they deserve the worst in fact on july
30th 2021 when safe moon dipped bin said
irresponsible whale i hope you get hit
by a bus now lucky for ben his wish
wouldn't come true because of course it
turns out ben was a irresponsible whale
the exact month he was complaining about
it in fact in the month of july when he
tweeted this he was selling over a
million dollars of safe moon lowering
the price even further than it already
was but what are the final figures how
much did he make well i enlisted some
fellow researchers to tally the total
amount and according to our calculations
he sold 16 million dollars worth of safe
moon and it looks like he profited
roughly 12 million dollars now will ben
get prosecuted for any of this i don't
know very few of these crypto cases get
prosecuted no matter how obvious it is
just very few people pay a penalty for
example a few months ago ice beside
admitted on tape to a massive scam and
nothing's happened to him yet so i can't
say what the future is for ben other
than i've done my best to report these
actions to the proper authorities and
you're welcome to look through the
transaction data yourself linked below
everyone is innocent until proven guilty
in a court of law and all of this is
allegation and opinion until proven
otherwise
wait so that's it
it's over he's not going to prison yeah
our work here is done now we let the
actual authorities take it from here
that sucks
the evidence is literally right there in
front of everyone well i don't know what
you want me to say it's messed up it
sure is
hey did you reach out to ben about all
of this i'd like to hear from him i did
but he didn't respond i think he's too
busy making more money with sick pranks
oh you lost all your life savings
whoops it's just a prank bro
oh thanks i needed that
this stuff gets really depressing after
a while
i don't mention it in fact i want to
show you something i think it'll make
you feel better sure what is it
let me clock out and i'll show you
[Music]
whoa
i didn't even know this was up here this
is beautiful yep
this is the real bomber's peak
gives you perspective
you know
they're not all bad
what you mean people
you sit in your room all day and talk
about scammers
but take a look around coffee
there are good people out there
wait so you're saying i shouldn't worry
about the scammers of the world
no
i'm just saying
you can't lose sight of the bigger
picture
look
i appreciate what you're trying to do
here you know if you don't mind i i
think i'm just gonna stay up here a
while stay as long as you like but i
gotta go back and serve the good people
of this city some ice cold drinks
[Music]
you